my name is Monique logo I'm my president
and shove the word is out in here which
is the largest and yes I want to give
you your question this is one who
doesn't well you would like to see a
panda yeah well I would like to see the
whole business need to be for the
benefit of people and go to society I
think that business can bring a lot of
flowers i would say benefits a lot of
contributions and that we need to have a
good balance between our people and
money and 2012 is also the International
Year of cooperatives in the world and I
hope that we will have a better
knowledge and recognition division of
this very powerful model which is based
essentially